how many times does the chorus repeat in
your favorite song and take a moment to
think how many times have you listened
to it chances are you've heard that
chorus repeated dozens if not hundreds
of times and it's not just popular songs
in the West that repeat a lot repetition
is a feature that music from cultures
around the world tends to share so why
does music rely so heavily on repetition
one part of the answer comes from what
psychologists call the mere-exposure
effect in short people tend to prefer
things they've been exposed to before
for example a song comes on the radio
that we don't particularly like but then
we hear the song at the grocery store at
the movie theater and again on the
street corner soon we are tapping to the
beat singing the words even downloading
the track this mere-exposure effect
doesn't just work for songs it also
works for everything from shapes to
Super Bowl ads so what makes repetition
so uniquely prevalent in music to
investigate psychologists asked people
to listen to musical compositions that
avoided exact repetition they heard
excerpts from these pieces in either
their original form or in a version that
had been digitally altered to include
repetition although the original
versions have been composed by some of
the most respected 20th century
composers and the repetitive versions
had been assembled by brute force audio
editing people rated the repetitive
versions as more enjoyable more
interesting and more likely to have been
composed by a human artist musical
repetition is deeply compelling think
about the Muppets classic Mahna Mahna if
you've heard it before it's almost
impossible after I sing Mahna Mahna not
to respond
doot-doot doot-doot repetition connects
each bit of music irresistible to the
next bit of music that follows it so
when you hear a few notes you're already
imagining what's coming next
your mind is unconsciously singing along
and without noticing you might start
humming out loud recent studies have
shown that when people hear a segment of
music repeated they are more likely to
move or tap along to it
repetition invites us into music as
imagined participants rather than as
passive listeners research has also
shown that listeners shift their
attention across musical repetitions
focusing on different aspects of the
sound on each new listen you might
notice the melody of a phrase the first
time but when it's repeated your
attention shifts to how the guitarist
bends a pitch this also occurs in
language with something called semantic
satiation repeating a word like Atlas ad
nauseum can make you stop thinking about
what the word means and instead focus on
the sounds the odd way the L follows the
T in this way repetition can open up new
worlds of sound not accessible on first
hearing the L following the T might not
be aesthetically relevant to Atlas but
the guitarists pitch bending might be of
critical expressive importance the
speech to song illusion captures how
simply repeating a sentence a number of
times
shifts listeners attention to the pitch
and temporal aspects of the sound so
that the repeated spoken language
actually begins to sound like it is
being sung a similar effect happens with
random sequences of sound people will
rate random sequences they've heard on a
repeated loop as more musical than a
random sequence they've only heard once
repetition gives rise to a kind of
orientation to sound that we think of as
distinctively musical where we're
listening along with the sound engaging
imaginatively
with the note about to happen this mode
of listening ties in with our
susceptibility to musical ear worms
where segments of music burrow into our
head and play again and again as if
stuck on repeat critics are often
embarrassed by music's repetitiveness
finding a childish or regressive but
repetition far from an embarrassment is
actually a key feature that gives rise
to the kind of experience we think about
as musical
you